I watched your video which is a big
viral yeah be blacker oh yeah yeah which
is wonderful thank this is something we
were just talking about auditions there
is that code when a casting agent wants
a black person there's no code they just
say can you be blacker they say that
yeah or they're like can you be a little
bit more urban okay I don't know I walk
in and I like my questions that we just
like how black do you want this done
where is she trying to escape the
Negroes vision because there's a
difference
yeah you show me the ring give me a walk
okay um well one being she's like in the
hood still it's like I do a lot of
McDonald's
[Applause]
like a middle friendly Negro is
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
we'll be right back yeah got one running
right now it's a brunch at McDonald's
and because black people can't go to
real bridge don't know what Wow so you
do one for brunch
yeah no line is like I'm so happy we
will sell brunch together and
I wasn't that late it was funny cuz it
was me and three other women who sounds
just like me and as soon as we started
recording their lit I want to raise the
Freddie okay yeah and I say it just like
that
just like that we can talk about how I
went home with a guy I left his house
and okay so I went home with a guy who
lives directly across the street from me
around like Cory and it said I got up
and was like were they rolling up there
with a mic is this break in the right
spot but I ended up leaving his house
with no shirt on just my bra a cardigan
leggings inside I left my phone a purse
my keys and I got to my door and I was
like I must've washed it off I just
forgot immediately when it was in his
house got across the street to get it
back but instead I climbed a fence never
didn't occur to you mid fence perhaps oh
you're like I could go back to where
this stuff is no but my roommate found
me trying to break a sliding glass door
with a shovel oh my god and my dog was
so skinny he thought someone was
breaking in so we ran into his room and
just immediately started peeing
everywhere to start feeding and my
roommate was like what are you doing and
he said I said hey
we are me
[Laughter]
[Music]